lieutenant governor of texas is one of
them we're happy to be joined by him
tonight he is of course dan patrick mr
senate governor thanks so much uh for
coming on so you are the lieutenant
governor of the state in which this
happened
tell us your thoughts yes
uh tucker since uh i was elected uh back
with greg abbott uh back in
2014 this is now the fourth
major mass shooting that we've had we
had sutherland springs the church we had
the walmart in el paso odessa and then
four years ago four years ago and one
week we had the shooting at santa fe
where we lost eight students and
two teachers and i will tell you tucker
that i've been to a lot of funerals and
a lot of services a lot of hospitals
nothing compares to what bill just said
about the loss of a child and i think
when crimes like this have this is pure
evil
that it impacts a whole nation
every parent every grandparent that has
a child
envisions what
what they would feel if it happened to
them this is something that goes to the
core of our soul all of us and and and i
hope the president tries to unify and
not divide us on this because we as a
nation
will always remember this these children
at this school
as adults one day will never forget it
these teachers this community of sixteen
thousand the school system only had four
thousand students in the entire system
tucker so these are crimes that get to
the very core of who we are as people
yes and i think as people we have to
look internally and and how did we get
here this was an evil act we there's a
lot that we're going to learn and it's
going to unfold in the days and weeks
ahead about this shooter but tonight
we've got to unify in prayer we have to
unify in faith we have to unify and who
are we
where we're tucker when i grew up and
most of the people watching grew up and
you we didn't have these situations
we didn't have mass shooters in our
schools we didn't have this evil and so
we really have to look at us as a people
as a country
because we can do a lot of things and
texas has done a lot of things after the
santa fe shooting
obviously we have to do more we have to
harden these targets so no one can get
in ever except through one entrance
maybe that would would help maybe that
would stop someone but it's really
bigger than that tucker it's we're a
core society we're we're a society
that's just at each other's throats all
the time and and and we're better than
we're better than this as a nation well
so let me just
keep sucker tonight yes i want to praise
the i want to praise the teachers
because i guarantee you we don't know
these stories yet but all those teachers
were heroic today i guarantee you
everyone did what they did in santa fe
they took their kids and they sheltered
them in place and they took them to
protect their lives yeah and teachers
shouldn't have to have to do that
they're in their i teach that
knows the elementary school teachers are
the best let me ask you about that
really quickly about
the prayer part of it so politicians
always say our prayers are with these
people and then you hear people push
back and say you know prayers aren't
enough prayers don't work when you say
your prayers are with the people you
seem to mean it
tell us why you think it's important to
pray in a moment like this
well first i'm a christian wasn't always
but jesus christ is my savior and that's
hope and hope in the bible says hope in
the bible tucker says that's something
that we expected and that will happen
and that's to be rejoined with our loved
ones in heaven again so that's the hope
we have but i can i can tell you tucker
that
that
what i've been through all of these
funerals and services over these years
the one thing i have seen
is people standing on the rock of their
faith and that's hard today you know
these people who are going through this
now these parents and grandparents they
have to understand we're going to walk
with them greg abbott myself the
legislature republicans democrats texans
29 million of us we're going to walk
with them but i see real faith tucker
and
what do you have in the absence of faith
you have no hope and i realize not
everyone's a believer and and i
understand that i'm just telling you
that that it's times like this where you
realize
how strong your faith is and some people
realize for the first time
they need god and so i believe at tucker
um what else this was a country founded
on faith tucker and that's why together
we have to come together as a people
don't politicize it don't point fingers
we'll figure all this out afterwards and
we'll do better and everyone will learn
from it but right now we have to say who
are we as a country who are we as a
people i believe in god i believe god
will be with these families and this is
a time that is just my heart breaks and
everyone watching heartbreaks i know it
does i know it doesn't matter where they
live they're with these people in uvalde
texas tonight
thank you john often asked politicians
about faith but i'm glad i asked you
thank you lieutenant governor dan
patrick of texas
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight